[Musique]
ce qui a changé depuis quinze jours
c'est que nous étions en phase de
croissance de l'épidémie et
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en phase de
décroissance de l'épidémie mais à un
niveau de performance et la décroissance
il ya aujourd'hui encore des centaines
de morts presque les même chiffre qu'au
mois de mars au mois d'avril
ça n'est plus deux heures tous les soirs
chez vous et chez vos collègues
c'est une information parmi d'autres et
donc à partir du moment où la société
reprend sa vie les protestations
reprennent leur vie
cette crise présente à un caractère
tellement inédit parfois tellement
surprenant dirais que voilà il me semble
que à la fois l'humilité le souci
d'efficacité nous conduit à regarder ce
que font les autres et dans quelle
mesure il est possible de nous en
inspirer
l' agence européenne du médicament a
indiqué ce week-end qu'elle pensait
pouvoir donner une validation un premier
vaccin d'ici à la fin de l'année pour
qu'ils puissent être distribués à partir
du mois de janvier c'est ce que l'
agence européenne donc ça veut dire
qu'en ce moment le gouvernement français
prépare une campagne de vaccination pour
le début de l'année mais au moins huit
autres candidats vaccins sont également
très avancé et selon cette spécialiste
tous les vaccins auront leur importance
ils pourraient être complémentaires
parce que certains pourraient être plus
efficace chez les personnes âgées ou
donner des protections de plus longue
durée ou prévenir aussi contre la
transmission du virus
amazon cristallise donc la colère des
petits commerçants
une pétition pour appeler au boycott du
site e-commerce a été lancé seat accusé
en effet de profiter de la crise
les signataires réclament qu'une taxe
exceptionnelle soit imposée au géant
d'internet
oui un gros problème amazon ce géant qui
ne respectent aucune règle qui ne paye
pas ses impôts en france ni dans les
autres pays européens qui bénéficient de
fraude à la tva massive également qui
détruit les emplois sur notre territoire
à chaque fois qu'un emplois créés chez
amazon
c'est entre 2,2 et 4.5 emplois détruits
ailleurs
son titre hashtag noël sans amazon elle
a été signée par 120 personnes des
syndicalistes des membres d'associations
des élus et des commerçants y ait une
sorte de bouc émissaire qui est amazon
je rappelle qu'ils représentent moins de
5% du commerce français donc je pense
qu'il faut être de savoir raison garder
pour l'instant le premier ministre a
annoncé qu on se fixait un objectif du
1er décembre pour leur permettre de
rouvrir si la situation sanitaire
continue à s'améliorer parce que vous
l'avez dit d'accord il ya des nouvelles
encourageantes mais elle reste grave
personne n'ose dire que le seul magasin
qui est un magasin physique ou en touche
c'est une librairie
or chacun sait que le virus se développe
beaucoup par le fait de toucher quand
vous achetez un shampoing chez franprix
vous ne touchez pas 30 shampoing vous en
toucher quand vous êtes l'année dans une
librairie c'est pour avoir un plaisir
physique ou n'osent pas le dire
après la volte-face de z takieddine
christian jacob a volé au secours de
leur ancien mentor des magistrats
ont-ils été aveuglé par un désir de
vengeance
voire même par une certaine forme de
haine
la question s'adresse à jean castex mais
c'est le ministre de la justice qui
prend le micro
le président va finir par tirer
directement dans le visage d'un jeune
homme l'image va arriver regarder ces
terribles paf une frappe présidentielle
en pleine poire pour ce pauvre petit qui
n'avait rien demandé
le garde des sceaux vous devriez le
savoir monsieur le député ne peut pas
qu'augmenter et moins encore intervenir
dans une affaire en cours et ce quel
qu'en soient les protagonistes il
s'emballe et vous quand c'est mauvais
tori spelling
vous êtes ici responsable devant nous
et c'est nous qui vous interrogeons et
nous attendent et merci monsieur bien
des jupes et leurs robes
je vous remercie